bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques kiosque votre
magazine culturel dédié sur l'actualité
culturelle sur saint quentin en yvelines
et ses alentours alors tout de suite le
sommaire de ce mercredi 23 septembre
nous recevons la belle s kelina
chanteuse folk venu du froid et l'aura
de l'édition 2014 d envol du scarabée
elle nous présente ses prochaines dates
de tournée avec un passage imminent à la
verrière au scarabée vendredi 25
septembre théâtre se risquer à la
metteuse en scène du spectacle de
création anna karénine de tolstoï à nous
expliquera les coulisses de ce projet
une grande première en france
la maison félix à montigny le bretonneux
expose jusqu'au 27 septembre christophe
baudin l'occasion dé découvrir l'art
abstrait lyrique mais aussi l'action
painting
mais avant de saluer nos invités retour
sur la journée du patrimoine ce week-end
avait donc lieu les journées du
patrimoine le public a pu visiter
différents sites exceptionnels parmi eux
le potager classé monument historique
depuis 1926 où le fort de saint cyr qui
héberge la médiathèque de l'architecturé
du patrimoine le potager du roi ses neuf
hectares de laboratoire autour de la
production de fruits et légumes rares et
plantes médicinales
le fort de saint cyr c'est plus de 3000
m² qui héberge 15 millions de photos
l'un des fonds les plus importants
d'europe
toute l'histoire de la photo y est
retracée de 1840 à 1990 et le fort ne
cesse de recevoir de nouvelles donations
prochaine acquisition celle du fonds de
willy ronis et nous débutons par la mise
à l'honneur du spectacle vivant avec
skis l'ina auteur compositeur et
interprète
bonsoir et cerise guy metteur en scène
de la pièce anna karénine de tolstoï
bonsoir skis line avant de vous
présenter on va découvrir ensemble votre
dernier clip je reviens sur un air de
mélancolie envoûtant je reviens au berry
j'aurais bien
à la maison
je reviens
miller ni par le tram à la morte saison
skis et l'ina vous êtes né en suède vous
avez fondé votre premier groupe à l'âge
de 13 ans et puis en grandissant vous ne
souhaitiez pas rentrer dans le circuit
des pubs
vous avez eu peur de perdre votre
liberté artistique vous quittez la suède
et vous partez en france alors arrivé en
france que se passe-t-il alors arrivés
en france après j'ai pas parti en france
pour ça mais je suis parti en france
pour changer de vie pour découvrir une
nouvelle envie de faire des choses assez
rapidement j'ai commencé à chanter dans
la rue dans une ville qui s'appelle
sarlat en dordogne et c'est de là que
j'ai commencé à faire des rencontres
d'autres d'autres artistes chanteurs
compositeurs français et petit à petit
j'ai pu créer un réseau ici qui
aujourd'hui voilà m'a permis de
rencontrer christophe bastien et florent
vintrigner avec qui je travaille sur
l'écriture et des chansons et qui ont
créé le répertoire que je te font
aujourd'hui et alors ce répertoire que
vous défendez aujourd'hui aux sonorités
plutôt mélancolique a fait l'objet d'un
album qui est sorti en janvier dernier
qu'elle sonorités on peut retrouver dans
cet album
moi je dirais assez folk
c'est un album assez folk épuré basse et
à la guitare sur la guitare et la
contrebasse l avoir après ya parfois
certains morceaux qui sont on ne peut
plus orchestrée que ça une meule en
cheval entre le folk américain à la
chanson française je trouve ca c'est
juste comme comme description de l'album
c'est très acoustique
oui il ya une inspiration également des
beatles oui peut-être
on peut entendre ça derrière il ya
beaucoup de vent une beaucoup de voix
les harmonies
oui tu as trouvé quelque chose d'assez
naturel oui on a eu envie de faire ça au
départ en tout cas parce que pour
vraiment mettre en valeur les textes les
mots et les histoires qui sont racontées
c'est une passe de présentation presque
deux mois de ma vie mais aussi de cette
rencontre avec le compositeur et auteur
avec qui je travaille alors avant de
poursuivre notre entretien petite
parenthèse pictural est ce qu'il vous
arrive t-il de pendre parfois s'il
m'arrive de peindre de peindre
oui ça m'arrive alors je vous propose de
découvrir l'exposition bodin qui a lieu
en ce moment à la maison félix de
montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au 27
septembre
à donner à la peinture figurative depuis
dix ans christophe baudin se révèle
aujourd'hui dans l'art abstrait ni rick
exposition proposée à la maison félix de
montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au 27
septembre
des toiles pluriel monochrome ou très
coloré et terré ou très graphique pour
réaliser ses toiles différents outils
peuvent être utilisés bros couteau
éponge ou peignent mais la plupart ont
ce point commun
l'action painting ensuite le tableau va
être terminé avec des projections et je
recherche toujours ce mouvement libre
donc 12-12 cette appellation de action
painting
on essaie de retrouver un mouvement et
on se libère on jette la peinture
carrément donc ça peut créer des
accidents il faut savoir apprivoiser ces
accidents les conserver et en tirer
meilleur parti
il suffit de diluer la peinture avoir
quelque chose de très fluide et dans un
petit gobelet pardon de vous projeter
comme ça et on a vraiment une sorte
d'explosion sur la toile
christophe baudin se reconnaît du
mouvement artistique appelée l'art
abstrait lyrique initiée par georges
mathieu ou l'art abstrait se définit par
l'absence de dessin pour laisser le
spectateur entièrement libre de son
interprétation
c'est à se demander comment peut naître
l'inspiration je fais attention vraiment
au moment à des moments cruciaux dans la
journée qui sont le moment d'éveil et le
moment dans normes et semant et ce sont
des moments clés qui permettent de
lancer une idée est parfois lorsque je
veux peindre je vais simplement faire
une sieste je lance cette idée et quand
je me réveille je suis prêt et souvent
la toile arrive et pour l'anecdote
l'illustrent peintres du surréalisme
délit procédé de la même façon pour
puiser son inspiration
avant de peindre
alors est ce que l'ina est ce que l'art
abstrait lyrique vous parle est ce que
ça pourrait correspondre à votre style
de peinture
je ne sais pas si je vais au style de
peinture mais ça a l'air un tout cas
pourra être très intéressant mais alors
d'avoir des belges des belles choses là
dedans ça vous permet de renforcer votre
inspiration musicale la peinture c'est
une autre forme d'expression
je pense que je me suis jamais servi de
la peinture pour pour enrichir la
musique c'est vraiment des choses
complètement différent pour moi ça n'a
pas une grande place dans ma ville mais
j'aime bien dessiner mais ça fait du
bien parfois de koszalin chargé oui
alors pour revenir sur quelque chose de
plus musical je sais que vous avez
participé aux envols du scarabée qui est
un tremplin musical en 2014 quelle
expérience en avez vous retiré en
gardez-vous un bon souvenir
oui vraiment voilà on a été déjà c'était
une super équipe très agréable a
vraiment été très bien accueilli on a
passé un bon moment bonne soirée
puis c'est un moment où qui nous permet
de présenter le projet pour un public
les connaît peut-être pas encore ce
qu'on fait est qu'ils sont là pour
découvrir de la musique justement donc
ils sont très à l'écouté
et ça c'est toujours très très agréable
après c'est aussi toujours un peu
particulier qu'on s'est quand même un
concours au final donc cédé des
conditions peu particulier pour pour
faire de la musique mais ça on apprend
beaucoup de choses aussi là dedans vous
avez l'impression que ça vous donner un
vrai coup de pouce que ça vous savez
réellement tremplin dans votre carrière
les tremplins c'est toujours ça en force
en fait ça en force ça peut détruire des
choses aussi si on en fait trop je pense
mais mais oui après là on a mis la
chanson à gagner donc on revient cette
année donc ça c'est super voilà ça nous
donne ça nous donne
une comment dire un retour positif sur
sur notre travail et puis on gagne de
l'expérience voilà alors cette fois ci
ne s'agit pas du tremplin du scarabée
mais de l'association la voix en scène
qui lance la première édition de son
tremplin musical le 7 novembre prochain
à l'estaminet de magny les hameaux
l'occasion pour les jeunes talents de se
faire repérer et formé par cet organisme
en coaching vocal et scénique
trois catégories sont ouvertes les
interprètes de moins de 16 ans les
interprètes de plus de 16 ans et les
auteurs compositeurs interprètes un jury
de professionnels décernera différents
prix doté de formation vocale ou
scéniques et d'enregistrement en studio
pour participer à ce tremplin
envoyez votre candidature vidéo à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran avant
le 10 octobre les critères quand on peut
le public
enfin quand le jury et même le public de
toute façon va va voter ça va être sur
l'interprétation sur l'expression
scénique et sur la technique vocale et
sur éventuellement aussi également
l'univers musical l'originalité est ce
qu'il ya un timbre particulier est ce
que voilà alors est-ce qu eminem vous
l'annonciez tout à l'heure vous étiez
lauréate de l'édition 2014 us tremplin
du scarabée
vous revenez en concert faire
l'ouverture de saison du scarabée
vendredi soir est ce qu'il y à d'autres
dates à venir pour vos concerts oui
alors on vous droit le 2 octobre à la
menuiserie qui ont été développés dans
tout ça c'est bien ça merci oui c'est ça
le 3 octobre à bonnières oui dans le 78
et où vous allez également participé au
festival fait des chansons
le 19 novembre oui je sais que vous
faites également différentes première
partie est ce qu elles certaines
premières parties de concerts qui vont
qui vous ont particulièrement marqué on
n'a pas mal fait les premières parties
de la rue kétanou et dont fait partie
florent vintrigner qui est auteur des
chansons et ça c'est quelque chose qui a
été une super expérience voilà avec un
public
super très bon accueil on a fait la
première partie aussi debout sur le zinc
la prochaine première partie qu'on va
faire c'est au festival la marne et on
va faire la première partie de cali
voilà gros concerts oui oui je pense on
a hâte de vous retrouver ce qu'ils nient
la merci d'être venu vous restez avec
nous en plateau il nous continuons
maintenant toujours dans le spectacle
vivant avec l'adaptation en français de
anna karenina de tolstoï avec vous serez
vous bonsoir alors serez expliquez nous
comment vous avez adapté ce roman russe
en français alors pour être claire et
précise
en fait je les gélules adaptation
anglaise parce que c'est une ode et
poussé tunindex adaptation anglaise qui
sait jouer avec énne énorme succès et
est à l'occasion de mes lectures je suis
tombé dessus et je me suis rendu je n'ai
pas vu j'ai pas vu le spectacle j'ai
simplement lui l'adaptation à préciser
parce que c'est important de préciser
quand il a vu pour ne pas être trop
absolument parce que je n'ai pas été
influencée ni par les images il par les
acteurs ni par la vision du metteur en
scène
je n'ai je n'ai fais que lire et j'ai
été éblouie parce que évidemment j'avais
lu le roman
évidemment qu'ils étaient kita
périssables une fois qu'on la lui on
peut pas même pas l'oublier c'est des
choses qui sont appelés les sables et
donc quelle intelligence quelle quelle
astuce parce que en effet le roman dont
on connaît le titre anna karénine ne
raconte pas seulement l'histoire d'anna
karénine mais aussi celle de levin
costentin nevin ces deux personnages
principaux du roman et la plupart des
adaptations ou des films y camperait des
séries j'ai tout vu en russe en tout ont
toutes les langues et de regarder
s'attache principalement sur le
personnage d'anna parce que c'est plus
romanesque beaucoup plus évidemment la
passion l'adultère
à tout ça et j'ai pensé qu'il y avait la
moitié du roman qui n'existaient pas que
tolstoï avait quand même écrite de jeu
personnages qui se kystique dont il a
fait des parcours parallèles évidemment
très contraire parce que anahita moral
on pourrait on peut dire que levin et
morale anna est amoral
mais hélas quand même il nous a
entraînés dans ces deux destins de ces
deux personnages qui ne se rencontrent
jamais enfin quand je dis jamais c'était
pas vrai c'est une seule fois à la fin
du roman est donc cette astuce qu'elle a
eue qu'elle a trouvée pour les mettre en
scène c'est d'avoir un dialogue virtuel
de sorte qu'on a tous les dialogues
intérieurs de la et de l'autre car ça
père et moi chaque fois que j'ai vu un
film j'ai dit mais il manque des choses
il manque des choses là je pense qu'il
manque en tout cas il manquera forcément
des mais pas l'essentiel de leurs
tourments de lors de leur passion de
leurs atermoiements de la chance de leur
culpabilité enfin donc elle est aussi
les deux personnages une façon comme il
l'a écrit d'une façon assez parallèle et
donc je les traduis tu es bien sûr et
j'ai fait la version française car on
n'est pas anglais on est français on a
des on a des impératifs de voilà et puis
je vois là j'ai fait j'ai fait le
spectacle que je voulais faire en tout
cas alors c'est une grande première en
france
bah oui ça s'est jamais fait dans ce
spectacle de création et gestion mais ça
vous allez rencontrer beaucoup mieux et
nous avons demandé à antoine cholet qui
interprète levin
comment ils appréhendent est de jouer
dans un spectacle de création
la marge de manoeuvre est un peu plus
lentement plus grande puisqu'il ya pas
de référent dont dans la tête et de nous
des comédiens et du public
il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de référence est pas comme
quand on joue cyrano ou là on a des
images qui arrivent tout de suite et
c'est on se confronte à des des
monuments vivant en plus je parle des
comédiens des mises en scène qui sont
très présentes donc là c'est compliqué
parce qu'on ne le pense qu'il ya une
concernant inconsciemment une recherche
et de légitimité et d'originalité ça
c'est peut être compliqué par avoir des
oeuvres alors on parle de liberté avec
le spectacle de création mais il doit
également y avoir des contraintes cerise
est ce que le spectacle de création
présente certaines contraintes et
contraint de plus appuyé que si c'était
une reprise
alors c'est très curieux parce que j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un vrai
classique que tout le monde connaît
cette histoire plus ou moins plus ou
moins c'est vrai mais j'ai vraiment pas
l'impression de faire une création avec
une écriture nouvelle avec des dix pays
je reste malgré tout dans un code de
théâtre classique avec une héroïne
classique avec un héros classique donc
je oui c'est une création est ce que ça
n'a jamais été monté en français bien
sûr mais je n'ai pas les contraintes
c'est réussir le spectacle voilà que ce
soit captivant d'un bout à l'autre que
que pendant qu on embarque tout le monde
dans cette déferlante de passion de
sentiments de sentiments contraires avec
ses désir d'absolu de déchirements et
puis de évidemment avec une fin tragique
pour anna comme tout le monde c'est
m'enfermant alors la contrainte c'est
également de réussir à travailler avec
ses comédiens
justement comment vous y êtes reprises
bon allez vous travailler avec vos
comédiens
alors il y avait deux choses je voulais
d'abord tous les avoir déjà vu jouer d
avoir déjà vu sur scène ça c'était un
premier point et deuxièmement que je les
connaisse enfin certains je les connais
comme un âge et j'avais déjà travaillé
avec elle et 12 ans et est en fait j'ai
tout stoy à ce génie absolu de tellement
décrire ces
personnage que je ne pouvais pas
dérailler c'est impossible de dernier
fallait qu'ils aient le physique et
tempérament
c'est tout écrit quoi vraiment au lidl
stoy l'impression ne regardait derrière
un petit derrière le trou d'une serrure
c'est tellement décrit avec minutie avec
tous donc moi j'étais j'avais cette
obligation de respecter ce qu'il
écrivait quoi matt hill and kings pour
savoir comment il s'était mise dans la
peau du personnage comment elle avait
interprété son rôle alors évidemment
j'ai lu le roman
et puis j'ai beaucoup écouté de musique
j'ai parce que parce que c'est ma façon
de travailler et j'ai écouté de la
musique russe
j'ai écouté les tchaïkovski fois là et
puis par par le physique par les
costumes évidemment ça fait déjà un an
que je me promène en toc de avec une
toque de fourrure sur l'athlète l'hiver
non ça c'est une boutade mais c'est vrai
aussi dit cerise la première
représentation a eu vendredi à ce que
vous avez une angoisse particulière
peut-être dans la réception du public
non c'est drôle non je voudrais que tout
soit prêt au point mais acteurs sont
prêts c'est la technique c'est tout la
mayonnaise
voilà c'est une question de mais je me
dis que c'est pas possible que les gens
n'aiment pas facile non
mais j'ai pas de voile a ajouté que tout
le monde soit prêt à tous les niveaux et
que voilà que tout tout tout mayonnaise
prenne
merci cerise je rappelle que vous
pourrez retrouver un à carey nina au
théâtre de l'espace coluche à plaisir
pour la première vendredi et samedi soir
à 20h30
et maintenant notre chronique cinéma
l'oeuvre du lait cooper fait l'objet
d'une exposition à l'espace noir et aux
clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 16 octobre
élève du célèbre illustrateur hervé
morvan il deviendra par la suite le
célèbre affichiste des films de charlie
chaplin notamment pour le dictateur
ville ou encore le kids lors de leur
sortie en 1972 mais léo cooper c'est
également la fiche du film emmanuelle
qui lui a valu le premier prix de la
fiche au festival de cannes en 1974 et
en 2012
il a publié le livre avoir une faim de
loup et autres expressions françaises où
chacune de ces illustrations explique un
proverbe français les surprenants
elle doit être simple
elle doit s'imposer comme une évidence
on doit y avoir que l'essentiel
c'est pourquoi j'ai inventé un mot le
mot évident ciel dans le moule vide
ancienne île à la vie il ya la danse est
un ancien et toujours au cinéma que
pensez-vous des films à l'affiché cette
semaine vos avis au micro de patrick
jacq des dixie mythe
moi ça va j'ai bien aimé en fait parce
que vu que bah on sait très bien de nous
il ya beaucoup d'hommes qui trompent
leur femme et tous et du coup ça raconte
un peu la réalité la frustrante
dérangeant et vitesse c'est vraiment
spécial c'est si horrible mais ça fout
quand même les jetons on a l'impression
de de vivre ce qu'il vit si vous voulez
doul quand même que c'est une
performance de la part de l'acteur keanu
reeves interprétation formidable
je sais pas quoi vous dire parce que
j'ai été j'ai été ému par ce film voilà
jeu d'acteur c'est ce que j'aime c'est
ce que je m'attendais à voir en fait
c'est être un très très bon film et que
je pense que dans toutes les familles il
ya des secrets et la manière de l'avoir
traité très très bien 1le les acteurs
sont formidables bien évidemment on les
connaît déjà un film formidable
énormément d'émotion des choses
extrêmement agréable donc voilà un film
d'une grande qualité et cette semaine
c'est lui beaucoup ont dû signer cette
d'elancourt qui nous donne son coup de
coeur sur les nouveautés aussi m
mon coup de coeur cette semaine le coup
de coeur du ciné cède donc cellos de
paolo sorrentino gros succès à cannes
magnifique distribution de grands
acteurs michael caine 82 ans est
remplaçable
et puis le grand avec est elle une
comédie douce-amère dramatique c'est
l'histoire de deux personnes qui
commencent à être relativement âgée et
réalisateur il en train d'écrire un
scénario il se retrouve dans un grand
hôtel l'hôte est un ancien chef
d'orchestre et ils vont comment
dirais-je
tous les deux se s'entraider pour que
l'on puisse continuer à travailler au
milieu d'une ambiance très particulière
avec des gens qui les entourent qui ne
semble pas voir le temps passer
donc un très beau film comédie douce
amère après la grande bellezza c'est bon
ce débat italien ce qui représente aussi
la renaissance du cinéma italien que
j'aime personnellement beaucoup et puis
un mini coup de coeur aussi quand même
pour le dernier film de jaco van dormael
le tout nouveau testament une comédie
complètement iconoclaste complètement
décalé après toto le héros après mister
nobody qu'on a encore en salles cette
semaine que je vous invite aussi à
découvrir
les nous retrouvons maintenant clair de
la varenne conférencière en histoire de
l'art bonsoir enfin c'est fort clair de
la varenne vous intervenez dans les
conférences en histoire de l'art que
propose le conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux l'ouverture de la
saison se fait avec vous mardi soir
prochain 29 septembre à 20 heures claire
est ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
en quoi consistent ces conférences alors
c'est une excellente idée pour aller
voir une exposition une de ses grandes
expositions parisiennes soit on connaît
déjà très très bien et puis on y va tout
seul soit si on veut parfaire son oeil
connaître le contexte le contexte
historique le artistique
si on veut mieux connaître l'artiste et
bien c'est bien de pouvoir suivre
auparavant une conférence que l'on
propose justement à montigny au
conservatoire donc je trouve que aller
voir une conférence avec tout un groupe
et une conférence hier quand on se
presse pour voir un tableau qu'on ne
voit absolument rien c'est pas très
agréable à voir des machins sur les
oreilles est passé une heure devant un
tableau où on vous dit exactement ce
qu'on voit bon ça perd un peu son temps
je trouve qu'être préparer ensuite venir
en toute liberté à son rythme avec ses
goûts ce qu'on aime
eh bien je trouve que c'est très bien
que ce soit préparée auparavant et c'est
vrai que régulièrement il ya beaucoup de
monde qui vient écouter ses conférences
pour ensuite aller tranquillement voir
les expositions quelquefois aussi
j'ajoute que des personnes non pas du
tout le temps d'aller voir les
expositions et elles sont contentes de
quand même avoir être au courant de ce
qui se passe à paris une petite
explication pour mieux savourer
l'exposition voilà alors vous ouvrait le
bal le mardi donc mardi soir prochain 28
septembre 20h donc ça dure deux heures
et j'essaye de faire 1h30 heure 3 heures
maximum deux heures et ce serait une
conférence sur villa flora l'étang
enchanté en ique en écho avec
l'exposition qui se déroule en ce moment
au musée marmottan valeur pourriez nous
en dire un peu plus alors c'est une très
très jolie exposition le titre ne dira
peut-être pas grand chose aux gens villa
flora l'étang enchanté
en fait c'était une magnifique demeure
qui se trouve à winterthur en suisse et
les propriétaires les another entre 1905
et 1935 à peu près ont constitué une
magnifique collection de nabi par
exemple bonon bonnart pardon vallotton
il ya aussi des défauts viste comme
matisse comme marqué comme manguin et
donc ils ont été amis de ces artistes
ils ont invité dans leur belle maison et
ils ont constitué une collection qu'ils
ont ensuite fourni je crois qu'il y
avait des tableaux même dans les salles
de bains voilà les sages les tableaux
étaient très rapprochés il y en avait
partout et donc voilà cette exposition
est en ce moment à paris pour la
première fois c'est la première fois
qu'elle quitte la suisse et qu'elle est
complet découvrir en france et donc
voilà c'est une pure merveille que cette
exposition et je conseille vraiment les
aux gens de venir écouter puis de venir
voir ensuite l'exposition alors citer
toutes les dates mise à l'agenda des
prochaines conférences serait trop long
mais vous pourrez retrouver bien sûr
toutes les dates sur la fiche l'adresse
pardon qui s'affiche à l'écran est ce
que vous avez quand même des coups de
coeur pour cette programmation
peut-être elisabeth vigée-lebrun alors
justement je reviens tout juste là deux
paris j'ai encore mes chaussures de
marche encore rouges d'avoir marché tout
fait journée et j'ai été voir en effet
madame vigée-lebrun alors c'est une
magnifique exposition la première sur
cette femme peintre à 18e jusqu'au début
des 19e qui était donc amis de marie
antoinette qu'elle a beaucoup représenté
qui a représenté la maternité elle a
fait beaucoup d'autoportraits l'était
ravissante et aussi avec sa fille julie
et puis vous savez qu'à la révolution et
les parties en exil
elle a peint toutes les cours
européennes elle était en italie en
autriche en russie et pour revenir
ensuite en france où elle a peint les
nouvelles cour impériale
alors merci clair on peut retrouver donc
toutes les dates à la fiche qui à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran
décédée
et avant de se quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas le théâtre impro
famille conflit de génération à la
merise c'est la compagnie déclic théâtre
attrape le vendredi 2 octobre à 20h30
monument en musique depuis 2013 dans le
cadre de l'opération nationale monuments
musique le centre des monuments
nationaux invite son réseau les
musiciens de l orchestre de paris pour
des rendez vous unique
premier rendez-vous à la villa savoye le
dimanche 27 septembre à 15h30 et à la
maison laffitte le samedi 26 septembre à
20h30 et enfin à ne pas rater le concert
electro deluxe à la batterie guyancourt
au vendredi 25 septembre à 20h30 fin du
que ce que pour cette semaine je vous
retrouverai avec plaisir
la semaine prochaine vous pourrez voir
et revoir l'émission sur notre site
internet très bonne soirée